[موسيقى]
تأخذ السيدة الرحمة مقدمة رعاية الحياة البرية
اثنين من حيوانات البانجولين الصغيرة في نزهة في
الغابة
[موسيقى
] تساعدهما في تعلم كيفية العثور على
طعام في
البرية أحضر فطيرتهما
للعمل لأنه
يمكننا الآن الحصول على طعامهما من
السوق
ووضعه في الثلاجة
ليأكلوا من
أجلهم عليهم أن
يصطادوا لأنفسهم الموجودون في إفريقيا وآسيا يعتبر البنغول
من الثدييات الأكثر تعرضًا للاتجار على وجه الأرض
مع جميع الأنواع الثمانية المعرضة لخطر
الانقراض.
وأنقذت وأنا ما زلت
أطفالًا ،
لذلك عندما أحضرهم ، يجب أن أبحث عن
فروع
لكسرها وفتح جميع الفروع
ورؤية الكركم
فيها ووضعها ثم أكون قادرًا على أكل
أعمال الرحمة لمحمية labasa للحياة
البرية في مدينة غابونو في ليبيريا ملاذًا
حيث تم منح الحيوانات التي تم إنقاذها
واليتيمية فرصة ثانية
في عام 2016 ، أدخلت الحكومة الليبيرية
قانونًا رائدًا يحظر
تجارة الصيد وأكل
الأنواع المحمية مثل حيوان آكل النمل آكل النمل (pangolin
a y).  فتحت شركة labasa في وقت لاحق أبوابها
لتوفير الرعاية للحيوانات المحتاجة ،
ولكن في بلد يتم فيه استهلاك لحوم الطرائد بشكل
تقليدي للحفاظ على الحياة البرية
آمنة ، يمكن أن يمثل تحديًا وفقًا
لمدير المحمية في السنوات الأربع
الماضية ، فقد أخذوا ما يقرب من 600
حيوان من قرود البانجولين وقرود المنغابي
للطيور الجارحة والتماسيح القزمية
ومقدمي الرعاية مثل juti day junior
ضروريان لبقائهم على قيد الحياة ،
سيأتي بعضهم كان يمزح في
سن مبكرة جدًا وعلينا
إطعامهم بالزجاجة لأنهم ما زالوا بحاجة إلى الحليب
منذ أن بدأت العمل مع
[ __ ] بينما أشعر في القرن الماضي أن
الحيوان جزء مني ،
لذلك كلما رأيت شخصًا يؤذي أي
شخص أشعر أنه يضغط على
شعرك لي ، فإن
ليبيريا هي موطن لثلاثة من
أنواع البنغول الثمانية في العالم وعلى الرغم
من حظر التجارة التجارية لهم
دوليًا ، يقدر الصندوق العالمي للحياة البرية
أنه تم الاتجار بأكثر من مليون حيوان آكل النمل الحرشفي
في العقد الماضي في
حين أن لحومهم تعتبر
الحساسية هي أن موازينهم المستخدمة في
الطب التقليدي في الصين
وفيتنام هي التي تدفع حقًا إلى طلب
البانجولي غير ضار ولا يمكنهم إيذاء
أي شخص
ليس لديهم أعداء طبيعيون إلا
مع البشر ،
لذا إذا خافوا من التدحرج في كرة
ولا يستطيع أي حيوان آخر  حارب مهاراتهم
ولكن هذا أيضًا يجعل من السهل علينا نحن
البشر أن نلتقطها ونفعل كل ما
نريد أن نفعله بها ،
لقد اعتنت جودي شخصيًا بكل
بطريق وصل إلى
محمية الحياة البرية لاباسا والتي
يزيد عددها عن 70 عامًا.
الهدف هو إعادة تأهيل
وإطلاق أكبر عدد
ممكن من الحيوانات التي تم إنقاذها في النهاية إلى الغابات
حيث تنتمي ،
أنا سعيد جدًا وفخور أيضًا بأنني قلت
[موسيقى]
بعد رعاية الحيوان
لبعض الوقت لمدة عام
ثم إعادته مرة أخرى  لفترة من الوقت
تشعر بالفخر حقًا
لأنك بالفعل تحب إنقاذ
حيوان أبيض آخر ،
هذا كوكب يستحق الحماية ،
أخبرنا كيف تجيب على المكالمة باستخدام
علامة التصنيف الرائعة على الأرض
لك